[Music]
ready go into the chapel and we're gonna
get married you have a good voice did
you hear it folks she's got a good voice
but that was a little pitchy that was a
little the theme song for a lot of
couples today because they said i do on
2 22 22. sally jeremiah also a channel 8
vocalist joining us now at the little
white chapel where many tied the knot
with why this rare date was so special
to them i bet you sally's going to sing
too
well couples from the east coast to the
west coast landed in las vegas today to
mark a very special time in their lives
many newlyweds say they want it this day
because it's a special number to
remember
getting married is a day many look
forward to in life and many were lucky
to choose 2
22-22 the once-in-a-lifetime experience
and you know the 2-2-2-2 is really
spiritual and it's new for new
beginnings it's been a plan at this
point for
a good couple months peter starjick has
been in the wedding industry for 47
years he works for elegant vegas
weddings and says as cover restrictions
have lifted in las vegas there's no
other place couples rather say i do just
today they had a total of 12 weddings it
took 60 years to reach 5 million who
knows
maybe
10 years will do 6 million hopefully
i'll be still around they want something
that reminds them that they're easy
easily remembered he won't forget it
because it's two two two two two
but for javier and stephanie from tampa
they went the extra mile to get married
at 2 22 p.m friends and family also came
to celebrate the twos are just really
important to show the two of us coming
together and
kind of the yin and yang of everything
it's getting better so vegas is coming
back
[Applause]
back out live i reached out to the
county regarding the amount of people
that have gotten married before 4 pm and
in a statement they say we anticipate
this to be one of our top 10 wedding
dates of all time from thursday through
2 22 22 p.m today we've issued 2939
marriage licenses and forecast at least
2 thousand 222 weddings
for now we're going to the chapel and
we're
going to get married reporting live
sally jaramillo live local now